nous allons devoir vivre avec le virus
il n'y a pas de vaccin et toujours pas
de traitement efficace contre le
coronavirus mais il faut recommencer à
vivre un peu a dit le premier ministre
edouard philippe
autrement la france va s'écrouler c'est
une ligne de crête délicate qu'il nous
faut suivre un peu trop d'insouciance et
c'est l'épidémie qui repart un peu trop
de prudence et c'est l'ensemble du pays
qui s'enfonce le 11 mai donc certaines
écoles vont recommencer à accueillir des
enfants les plus jeunes d'abord le 18
mai ce sera au tour des collégiens tout
ça sur une base volontaire les commerces
aussi pour en rouvrir leurs portes
sauf les restaurants les cafés et les
bars les transports en commun peuvent
rouler à 70 % de leurs capacités
le port du masque la bête noire des
autorités françaises depuis le début de
la pandémie sera généralisée partout est
obligatoire dans les transports pour
mesurer l'effet de l'allègement des
mesures de confinement le gouvernement
compte faire tester massivement les
personnes présentant des symptômes nous
nous sommes fixé l'objectif de réaliser
au moins 700 mille tests virologiques
par semaine 11 mai le gouvernement
reporte la mise en place d'une
application controversé pour suivre les
traces de la contamination
mais quand mettre en place des brigades
lorsque les identifier les contacts des
personnes atteintes de lakovic 19 et les
placer en isolement préventif la
patience de nos concitoyens à retrouver
une vie sociale
je crois que nous la partageons tous dès
le 7 mai prochain des départements
seront classés en vert ou en rouge les
autorités locales pourront ainsi adapter
le plan de déconfinement à ce que le
premier ministre a qualifié de réalités
du terrain d'abord frustré du manque de
temps pour étudier la stratégie du
gouvernement les députés d'opposition
ont fait part de leur indignation et de
leur colère à présent nous voici rendus
après une gestion calamiteuse à une
sortie hasardeuse sous et incohérent
voilà ce que reprochait une majorité des
députés de l'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale
à cette présentation du plan de
déconfinement du premier ministre
edouard philippe
une opinion qui rejoint celle de la
majorité des français selon les derniers
sondages six sur dix ne fait plus
confiance au gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron il a jusqu'au 7 mai prochain pour
prouver à la france que son plan c
preuve de prudence
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada paris